revolver ocelot has spent the Metal Gear
Solid series orchestrating world events
to further his own goals but to simply
describe him as a villain would
understate how complex a character he is
born on June 6 1944 and named Adamski
his mother was the legendary soldier
known as the boss shortly after birth
however he's taken by the Philosopher's
a powerful group of political figures in
1960 he defects to the Soviet Union but
unbeknownst to his comrades a danske is
operating as a spy for both the CIA and
the KGB under the orders of the
Philosopher's the very group that tore
him away from his mother Adams Co goes
on to attain the rank of major in the
Russian group where he operates under
the name Ocelot then in 1964 Ocelot
helps steal the most dangerous weapon in
the world a screw propelled nuclear
missile launcher called the shadow hood
the basis of the metal gears ocelots
commanding officer Colonel Vulcan
detonates a nuclear missile in Russia in
response Ocelot is tasked with covertly
helping a u.s. Marine codenamed naked
snake to eliminate the shadow HUD and
Vulcan and kill the boss who was posing
as a defector that was some fancy
shooting you're pretty good
three good however it gets more
complicated Ocelot is actually a triple
agent and is tasked by the US government
with acquiring a vast pool of money that
has been amassed by the philosophers
after Operation sneakier he hands over
the advanced metal gear weapon plans to
the CIA he then tracks down one half of
the cash reserve the Philosopher's were
after for himself this essentially makes
him a quadruple agent take about kijima
dizzy racket later Ocelot uses a
struggle between the CIA and the
Pentagon over their half and secures
that for himself too but the entire
money reserve under his control Ocelot
becomes a force to be reckoned with
it seems implausible but his wider plan
appears to be altruistic Ocelot wants to
weaken the influence that the
Philosopher's have over the u.s. but
needs a few more years of scheming and
subterfuge to do it
along with his co-conspirator major zero
Ocelot founds a group called the
Patriots although he operates as a spy
for them he also begins to resent their
ideologies in Metal Gear Solid 5 the
phantom pain Ocelot
during two nuclear incidents in 1995 and
1999
Big Boss formerly naked snake is left
for dead
the Patriots keep him alive by inducing
a coma which upsets Ocelot who had come
to share many of big boss's ideologies
from this point on ocelots mission was
to recover the body of Big Boss and
bring down the Patriots to do this he
aligns himself of liquid snake one of
the sons of Big Boss officially adopting
the codename revolver ocelot convinces
liquid to take over shadow moses and
demand big boss's body but wait he was
also in fact secretly working for the US
president George Sears and trying to
acquire the test data from Metal Gear
Rex doing so would amazingly still be
part of his grander plot against the
Patriots from here Ocelot sells the
Metal Gear Rex data on the black market
to multiple nations he also uses
advanced transplant techniques to
surgically attached the deceased liquid
snakes arm to replace his lost one don't
think about it too hard
Kojima sign we didn't I live on through
this arm
a combination of drugs nanomachines and
hypnosis also allowed him to establish a
liquid snake persona within himself why
while to throw off the Patriots of his
trail of course
then in 2007 s Manhattan incident Ocelot
steals Metal Gear RAY under the
direction of the Patriots and escaped
into the Hudson River during this siege
Ocelot comes face-to-face with Solid
Snake and the liquid persona takes over
his body in what seems like a
nanomachine enabled possession still
completely unaware that Ocelot was a
double agent acting against them
the Patriots construct Arsenal gear a
submersible fortress capable of
monitoring the entire internet and
controlling the USS Armed Forces
it was ultimate unchallengeable power
revolver ocelot then joins forces with
solidus snake the third son of big boss
and former President of the United
States don't question it accidentally or
purposefully maybe crashes Arsenal gear
before escaping inside Metal Gear RAY
again from this point onward ocelots
feigned alliance with the Patriots
disappears entirely and he begins his
assault on them Ocelot replaces liquids
armed with a cybernetic one and
surrenders his mind entirely to liquid
taking up the mantle of liquid Ocelot
aka the baddest dude in town he shapes
the world's war economy by taking
control of five private military
companies and then infiltrates the
Patriots is all-important AI Network his
final act is to attack an orbital AI
core owned by the Patriots and as he
believes it destroy the Patriots as a
result during the final knock-down
drag-out fistfight with snake the
original Ocelot personality begins to
re-emerge and he displays mannerisms
first scene with his clash against Big
Boss fifty years prior Ocelot believed
that without the Patriots chaos would
create the world Big Boss dreamed of
where soldiers would always matter he
died believing he succeeded ocelots
final words to Solid Snake were I am
liquids doppelganger and you are his and
you're pretty good
you're pretty you're pretty good good
you